the boys season two was bigger stranger
and somehow even darker than the first
revelations about compound v a hip new
heroine as the voice of the seven and
closure for billy butcher so how did
that all shake out beware
of huge spoilers ahead it's been clear
since the beginning of the boys that
homelander is a dangerous sociopath with
little regard for human life
a tendency to be highly manipulative and
a horrible killer
temper the question is always if he can
really be kept in check and by the end
of season two
it looks like almost nothing about
homelander is stable anymore
early on his twisted relationship with
madeleine was the main check on his
behavior but he ended up killing her
after a perceived betrayal
in season two he seems to draw strength
and comfort from both stormfront and his
son ryan even though the boy isn't
always what he hoped for
by the end of the season finale
stormfront is at death's door and ryan
has
finally definitively chosen a different
path for himself
rejecting his father's path of violence
and manipulation and while he leaves
with butcher
butcher hands ryan over to a more
responsible party that leaves homelander
absolutely untethered in the final
moments of the season
and whatever happens with him next will
definitely be an extremely
volatile situation in the penultimate
episode of the second season
the u.s government is rocked by a
strange and violent attack in the halls
of congress
just as a congressional committee is
about to launch a hearing
investigating vat and the creation of
superheroes heads begin exploding all
around the committee room
literally the season finale opens with
stormfront in particular feeling rather
optimistic about the attack
even if she doesn't know who did it by
the end none of the major characters
know the culprit
congresswoman newman a soup with
extremely potent mental powers who's
been hiding in plain sight this entire
time
what is newman's endgame is she out to
unmake and
unseat vaude as the world's premier home
base of superheroes is she just a pure
super villain trying to sow chaos
we don't know but we do know she's
dangerous in more ways than one
in the wake of stormfront's defeat the
boys go their separate ways
huey is happy to stay with annie and try
to make the relationship work in a more
stable environment and eager to let go
of the chapter in his life where he
seemed to live
between two worlds little does he know
though that he seems to be on the verge
of living some kind of double life yet
again
the last thing we see him do in season
two is sign up for a job
in congresswoman newman's office and
while that might not necessarily put him
right in the thick of suit battles again
it does put him right next to one of the
most dangerous soups on the planet
how long until he realizes he's been
wrapped up in another super scheme
will butcher and the boys come calling
if they realize what newman really is
either way it's clear that huey is
already on the verge of getting pulled
right back into a world he was eager to
leave
one of the defining arcs of the boys has
been the gradual breakup of the original
stable lineup of the seven as we saw it
at the beginning of season one
starlight's edition was supposed to be
the only major replacement after the
retirement of lamplighter but since then
homelander has struggled to hold his
super team together
as the series goes on both the deep and
a train are gone
starlight is full on rebelling and maeve
is beginning to have second thoughts
near the end of season two it looked
like the only loyalists left in the
group were the newcomer stormfront
and the silent enforcer black noir now
both of those allies are seriously
incapacitated
maeve takes noir out by feeding him an
almond joy activating a tree nut allergy
that may not have killed him
but has at least left him nearly brain
dead with no real prognosis
as for stormfront she's still alive but
she's been left
limbless and outed as a literal nazi
suffice it to say the seven will look
very different again in season three
season two of the boys featured a lot of
minor arcs on top of the major ones
and one that paid off in a hilariously
twisted way by the season finale was the
dual redemption journey of the deep
and a train both were expelled from the
seven for different reasons over the
course of the first two seasons
and both hoped to leverage the influence
of the church of the collective to get
back in bots good graces
of course it didn't go quite the way we
may have thought
one other thing you uh you ripped your
best
what your gill is showing
cover it up it's disgusting the deep
spent all season making sacrifices
changing his behavior and doing what he
was told by the church in the hope that
the seven would see the light
then at the 11th hour a train steals
church files on stormfront and leaks
them to the boys
getting her ousted and by extension
impressing church leadership and vaught
with his initiative
so while atrain is now back in the
seventh the deep is left once again
without a home base
continuing to fail no matter what he
tries when the dust settles a lot of
things are different setting the stage
for a third season that will probably be
even more unpredictable than the first
two
among the big changes courtesy of grace
mallory is that the boys are free men
because they helped take down stormfront
all charges against them have been
dropped
and they've even got the opportunity to
join a newly established office to keep
an eye on supes if they want it
for now none of the boys with the
possible exception of huey seem to want
that job
butcher is grieving mm has returned to
his family and frenchie and kimiko are
off to try and build a life together
huey's attempt to land a job with
congresswoman newman might get him a
position in the government office
eventually but for the moment we've seen
the end of the boys
at least until another soup threat
brings them back together
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one